c'est une prison qui est contrôlée par
les forces russes et où étaient détenus
des soldats ukrainien ce qui avait
défendu l' usine à marioupol d'azov
talent donc ce sont des prisonniers de
guerre très prisé par l'ukraine qui
essayait de négocier leur échange contre
des prisonniers russes la russie accusé
l'ukraine d'avoir tiré sur ce site
l'ukraine dément et accuse la russie
d'un crime de guerre et d'avoir
délibérément tiré sur ce site situé dans
le territoire qu'elles contrôlent
afin de couvrir ses propres crimes de
guerre torture est peut-être le décès
déjà de certains de ces prisonniers bien
sûr il est impossible de prouver l'une
des versions ou l'autre mais ce qu'on
sait c'est que les familles des détenus
et les autorités ukrainiennes avaient
très très peu d'informations sur le sort
de ces prisonniers ignorer même s'il
était encore en vie et c'est quelque
chose qui pour les experts ukrainiens
peu peu
augmentez alimenter l'argumentation
comme quoi les russes auraient
délibérément tiré sur cette structure
pour justifier du tc des prisonniers qui
auraient été en réalité tué par d'autre
part par les mauvaises conditions et les
tortures et les violences qui avaient
lieu à l'intérieur de cette
cité de détention